many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism
why does Stoics focus on negative
visualization this is an excellent
question particularly given that one of
the promises of stoic philosophy for its
practitioners is that ultimately they're
going to be living a life that is as
free and untroubled as possible free of
negative emotions so it's a little
paradoxical isn't it to think that by
focusing on the negative on what could
go wrong on what might be heading our
way that we would get rid of these
negative emotions there are very clear
benefits to engaging in negative
visualization regularly and we're going
to talk about those in a moment but
before that let's get clear on what
we're actually talking about when we use
these terms negative visualization
especially since if you read through
classic stomach texts you're not going
to find that term anywhere instead what
you're going to see is the Stoics
telling you to for example keep death
before your eyes and you know things are
going to go well with you or before you
go into a situation think about this
sort of thing or consider all these
different possibilities or when you go
to kiss your wife or child remind
yourself that they are a mortal being
and will die and then you won't be quite
so upset when it happens which may
strike us as very morbid or even cruel
so what's going on here are the Stoics
indulging in a sort of thinking negative
thoughts for the sake of thinking
negative thoughts are they all Downers
are they all people who are pessimistic
no that's not the case and I want to say
something about the opposite extreme -
this is not some sort
homeopathy of the mind where you're
taking just a tiny tiny little bit of
negativity almost a trace amount and
that will clear out all the other things
that you're going to feel sort of the
analogy of homeopathy no you're going to
actually think about you're going to
consider you're going to visualize
things that could go wrong or will
eventually happen that we typically view
as negative from the perspective of
stoic philosophy these are not always
negative but from the perspective of the
larger culture both in ancient times and
in our present these are viewed as bad
if you're at all unclear about what
we're talking about maybe a few concrete
examples could be helpful so imagine
that you're heading into some kind of
contest like an athletic contest you're
playing a game against somebody and
there's some stakes maybe you've put
some money on the game maybe people that
you care about are watching you and want
you to win
maybe you just are naturally competitive
person and you think about what could go
wrong within the game and all the
different ins and outs you know you you
think about your opponents and how
you're going to face that more if it's
and you know something like doing a long
jump you think about the conditions of
the track and you run this through your
mind not necessarily for a long time but
before you actually engage in it that
would be negative visualization thinking
about the possible loss of loved ones as
I just brought up with epictetus is
another one we you're in a relationship
with somebody and you think I'm so happy
that I have this this new relationship
my life feels complete and you remind
yourself that it could end at any moment
that they could be taken away from you
for all sorts of different reasons
that's negative visualization as well
imagine that you've got a very important
meeting an interview let's say a job
interview you're going in
and you're going to try to present
yourself in the best way and you think
about the sorts of questions that might
get asked that could stump you or you
consider the matters that you're a bit
embarrassed about in your CV or your
resume and whether they're gonna probe
about that and we could go on and on all
the different things you know what
happens if you spill coffee on your
shirt what happens if you walk in and
it's very clear that you're overdressed
or underdressed how are you going to
handle it these are all negative
visualization I'd mentioned that there
are some benefits to engaging a negative
visualization and this is exactly why
the Stoics advocated as a practical
exercise to engage in on a broad scale
daily but also to do when we're heading
into difficult situations so what are
those benefits if you're engaging in
negative visualization ahead of time
when you actually get to the potentially
disturbing event you will find more
times than not that it may still feel
bad but it doesn't feel as bad as if you
hadn't done the negative visualization
so that's a very important benefit
obviously the further along you get on
the stomach path the less that that you
would be disturbed by things but for the
rest of us this is very important
another thing that it helps you to do is
to think about the possible outcomes and
to have a certain sense of perspective
on the probability of those quite often
the really catastrophic things that we
fear or are averse to they're not that
likely to happen and by reflecting on
that you may feel a bit better about it
it's usually the smaller scale
annoyances that are more likely to
happen and then you can focus your
energy on that and that brings us to the
third benefit which is when you think
about what could happen
and how things might go from your
perspective wrong you can also think
about what resources you would have to
deal with the situation what would you
need to do in order to be a little bit
more prepared and even thinking about
that preparation can sometimes give you
the edge so that when you're in the
actual situation time bound you can
respond in real time in a way that's
effective for you in that situation
finally the last part is you can also
think about let's say this bad thing
does happen what's still the case it
allows you to appreciate what you still
do have you know when somebody has a
consoling thing well at least you have
your health now health of course is a
preferred indifferent for Stoics but
that's still something you know quite
good something useful that that's an
observation that can be very helpful
within the situation so negative
visualization can help us in each of
these four ways and it does some other
things as well where would you go if you
want to learn more about this as I
remarked if you go to the classic stoic
text which I highly recommend you're
gonna find them referring to this many
times but not using the word negative
visualization you're also not going to
see them using another term which comes
about later on pramatta taught Co
malorum the again the thinking ahead of
time about the bad things that that
could happen but if you do read you know
Marcus Aurelius
Epictetus Seneca you'll see them talking
a great deal about concrete examples
general principles and how to do this if
you want to read the more modern stoic
literature there's plenty of books out
there all you have to do is type in
negative visualization here you see a
number of blog entries and videos come
up as well so there's a there's a vast
amount of literature and other material
out there that can help you with this
but it is something that you have to
practice you get better at it the more
you do it if you found this answer
helpful for you then please share it
with others who might benefit from it
this work is entirely supported by
crowdfunding on my patreon site so if
you find it valuable consider becoming a
supporter at patreon.com slash Sadler